une journée placée sous la contrainte du
coronavirus ce mardi 14 juillet la
france a célébré sa fête nationale de
manière quelque peu inédite crise du coc
vite 19 oblige le traditionnel défilé
n'a ainsi pas pu se tenir sur les
champs-elysées mais sur la place de la
concorde et pour respecter les
conditions sanitaires seulement 2500
personnes ont pu y assister
un cortège également réduit avec deux
mille militaires contre 4000
habituellement caissier éboueurs
infirmiers il était aussi les invités
d'honneur du défilé héros ordinaire de
la crise du court aux navires us que la
france vient de traverser un hommage à
d'ailleurs été rendu aux soignants
acteur majeur de la lutte contre
l'épidémie
une cérémonie présidée par le chef de
l'état à l'issue de laquelle ce dernier
il a accordé une interview au palais de
l'elysée lors de cette prise de parole
le président français a étayé son plan
de relance économique et face à la crise
du coronavirus et surtout celle d'une
potentielle deuxième vague
emmanuel macron a annoncé une mesure
forte
la meilleure prévention ce sont ce qu'on
appelle les gestes barrière contre le
virus
les masques se tenir à distance et le
gel hydroalcoolique et donc il faut
continuer d'appliquer ces gestes
barrières là dessus on voit des
faiblesses donc j'ai demandé à ce qu'on
passe une étape au gouvernement et je
souhaite que dans les prochaines
semaines on rende obligatoire le masque
dans tous les lieux publics clos on le
fait dans les transports ça marche très
bien mais c'est un peu erratique dans
les lieux publics clos
nous allons on va observer la situation
nous mettre en situation de pouvoir par
exemple à partir du 1er août le rendre
totalement obligatoire une allocution
télévisée qui n'a pas vraiment fait
l'unanimité sur twitter l'opposition n'a
pas tardé à tacler le chef de l'état
pour une fois il a entièrement raison
macron nous explique depuis dix minutes
que ses trois premières années il a
échoué s'est trompé mais ensuite il
assure qu'en fait ce sont les français
qui n'ont pas compris
bref c'est encore notre faute les
français attendent et que le président
tire les leçons de la crise
ce à quoi il avait semblé vouloir
s'engager espoir vain
pas de changement de cap justice sociale
et fiscale écologie démocratie féminisme
ne sont pas sur le chemin présidentielle
les riches acclament macron ils ne
paieront rien de plus la vie est belle
pour eux macron brasse du vent mais
toujours rien de concret pas de vision
claire la trajectoire hollande se
précise deux ans à tenir
en parallèle plusieurs manifestations se
déroulaient à paris des soignants mais
aussi des gilet jaune rassemblés pour
crier une fois de plus leur colère
un cirage de pompes ans et on va
embellir la chose on veut comment nous
faire croire plein de choses en fin de
compte qu'on arrête de bar tout
simplement nous prendre pour des
blaireaux
on a toujours appelés à converger avec
avec le personnel hospitalier
d'ailleurs nous aujourd'hui on n'est
plus chez les jeunes on est citoyen en
colère
voilà parce que ça représente toutes les
luttes et aujourd'hui c'est important de
toutes les luttes convergent semble loin
de fédérer le président français doit
donc encore répondre à de nombreuses
inquiétudes dans un futur proche et
l'exécutif à devoir finaliser les
derniers détails de l'accord sur le
ségur de la santé mais aussi se pencher
sur un des dossiers les plus
controversées du quinquennat la réforme
des retraites